I'm Ali and this is my son Raphael I am
hoping to learn American Sign Language
over the next 60 days yay when Raphael
was born he failed his newborn hearing
screening at the hospital at six weeks
old we were given the diagnosis that he
has profound unilateral hearing loss in
his right ear which means he is
completely deaf in his right ear and
that means there's a lot of question
marks he does have normal hearing in his
left ear
but I've talked to parents all over the
country with children's unilateral
hearing loss and their experiences are
vastly different in terms of
communication some kids do totally fine
with just one working year
some kids rely completely on American
Sign Language as their form of
communication and some lie somewhere in
between well we got that first diagnosis
from the audiologist the experience
there was a little bit dry you know she
sort of gave us the diagnosis and then
immediately tried to tell us a certain
brand of hearing aid she sort of
presented it as like this is the only
solution she sent us to an ENT and we
didn't have a great experience there
either we felt sort of very lost after
that we decided to get a second opinion
so we went to Children's Hospital and we
found an audiologist who gave us the
same diagnosis but talk to us more about
different options we felt more listened
to the very next day I got a phone call
from someone reaching out to me saying
you know we received your son's
diagnosis and we're gonna put you in
touch with a group called parent links
which is a community for parents of
children with hearing loss so you can
connect with other parents who are going
through the same thing it's been
incredible to be enveloped by this
amazing community of parents and
educators and people who are advocates
for children with hearing loss that's
one of the reasons why I'm really
interested in learning and itself just
to give him another cool another way of
communicating with him I just want to
give him every opportunity to succeed
I think he's extraordinary at the very
beginning I started taking some online
ASL lessons and at first it was very
basic it was just sort of like worth so
after about a week and a half of online
I'm learning a lot of vocabulary words I
was sick last week so I know that I was
sick the hard part for me right now and
the frustrating is like putting it all
together and trying to create sentences
because the
in the sentence structure is very very
different every time I look at my kid
and I see that he knows a sign for more
you want more or I think about how yes
it might be difficult but I want to keep
going and I want to be able to help him
communicate more it was really hard
learning online only because I didn't
have any ones to heard of like feedback
way and then I actually started working
with an ASL tutor Loni we just had our
first meeting and it was really
intimidating at first as soon as I saw
her I you know said hi I'm Ali nice to
meet you you know and she was happy that
I knew that but then I just sort of
forgot myself and started talking to her
I said we're gonna go to Kate's desk
right now and get some paperwork
and she had to remind me I'm deaf but
she made me feel at ease right away cuz
she could tell but I was very nervous I
did a lot of writing things down today
because I was a little overwhelmed I
know that's okay it sort of at the
beginning but I want to be respectful of
Lonnie and not sort of have to write
everything down all the time it was
really great because actually having
one-on-one time to go back and forth and
practice my signs with an actual person
who knows the language it was just like
a whole nother world of learning so I'm
gonna quiz myself on some of these
flashcards that Lonnie and I have been
working on I will not look but I'll show
you so this sign is daughter so I'm
about halfway through one of the things
I really need to start working on now
too is to actually have conversation and
that's where it gets a little bit tricky
because ASL is its own language there's
two different things they're signed
English which is do you want a banana or
an apple but in ASL that same sentence
would simply just be apple banana which
that's a really rudimentary example but
a lot of things like that very tricky to
sort of get the grammar and moving
things around into sentences this is
Lonnie
she's my tutor for ASL it's important
that I have a tutor because part of the
grammar is your facial expressions so it
really helps to have another person
[Music]
one of the first things I learned how to
say is how do you say so I was trying my
hardest to be able to communicate only
using sign it's been a little over 60
days since this whole endeavor started
and I'm feeling really good about my
progress I feel like I'm finally
starting to like put sentences together
I'm getting really excited to start like
actually speaking in ASL
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now that I've had sort of a taste word
I'm really falling in love with the
language I feel like this is something
that's gonna bond us and it's going to
make him understand that sort of no
matter what he needs he'll always be
able to communicate with me
[Music]
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part subscribe here that was my
part